so last night we had the third
Democratic presidential debate this one
with ten candidates total instead of ten
candidates across two nights happened on
just one night and this was actually in
just about every sense the best debate
so far and I'll tell you who I think did
well I'll tell you what I think the
impact of it will be but it as far as
the debate goes yes the ABC Univision
moderators still asked cartoonishly
stupid questions which I will discuss
but I had sort of complained on Twitter
three hours do we really need three
hours of debate particularly when at
most of these 25 minutes go by before
the first question is even asked between
sports like introductions and an
immediate commercial break and a video
montage and opening statements you don't
get to the first question very often
until nearly 30 minutes in they didn't
do that they started with the first
question very very quickly or at least
opening statements it ended actually
like 20 minutes shy of the three-hour
mark and in the end all the other
debates had gone long this one went
short and was far more substantive they
spent I think it was the first a 30 to
35 minutes of questions I'm going from
memory here was just health care did we
learn an insane amount about everybody's
health care plans maybe not but what did
happen and this is the whole point when
you spend more time on one topic even
when it is 10 people on the stage which
is a whole other problem even if you
don't get that much more detail from
most people about their plans it starts
to become clear who has nothing more
than just two or three bullet points
about what they would do Joe Biden
starting to stumble about the dynamics
of if you can't afford it or if you
can't afford it or whatever else the
case may be Elizabeth Warren who had
been accused of backing off of Medicare
for all at least in rhetoric during
yesterday's debate coming back fully and
saying Medicare for all is the way very
astutely rebutting this idea that taxes
would go up by saying very clearly yeah
but who cares if taxes go up the total
cost goes down because you don't have
premiums and co-pays and all of this
other stuff let's talk about some of the
different elements of this that I think
will impact it overall let me get out of
the way the moderators did a better job
than in many previous debates and by
focusing longer periods of time on one
issue they were playing a role of
furthering depth on some topics
including climate change in health care
etc but there was still no shortage of
completely ridiculous questions at one
point asking Bernie Sanders to say hey
okay you're you're a socialist and
Nicolas Maduro in Venezuela is a
socialist what do you make of that and
then Bernie Sanders having to explain
different types of socialism this
actually I said it on Twitter and some
people agreed with me some people went
after me Bernie's policy if Bernie's a
Democratic Socialist privately okay
maybe he is Bernie's policies are social
democratic policies in line with
capitalist countries in Northern Europe
that are well regulated and used the
fruits of the capitalist system to
disproportionately help the least among
us that's Bernie's policy and this is
one of those things where I've been
saying it for years at this point and
like 75 percent of my audience is with
me 25 is not if he all along just said I
considered myself a Democratic Socialist
in my youth or whatever or not even
mentioned that I'm a social democrat my
policies are in line with countries that
are capitalist countries Nicolas Maduro
and that form of faux populist so-called
socialism whatever it has nothing to do
with what I'm doing and to even suggest
the comparison is absolutely absurd he
can't do that because he does call
himself a socialist and then he has to
make finer distinctions whatever the
question was ridiculous
didn't further our understanding at all
of Bernie Sanders platform they asked
Cory Booker about is he gonna push his
vegan diet on everyone I'm paraphrasing
here just ridiculously stupid question
but potentially a missed opportunity for
Cory Booker where he could have talked
about animal welfare he could have
talked about the importance of diet he
could have been humanizing in self
humanizing in some way and it ended up
just being a stupid question and and
kind of a non-answer now one of the
bigger narratives that I was paying
attention to which is a real narrative
unlike corporate media
often foments totally bogus narratives
nobody cares about think it was before
the second debate CNN was pushing what
will happen when booed and jej and
O'Rourke go against each other it's like
nothing no one cares about that they're
each polling 2% totally fabricated
narrative there was a real question
yesterday there were really two primary
questions for me number one how to what
degree would Bernie and Warren who are
the two progressive frontrunners Biden
of course being more of a center-left
frontrunner would Bernie and Warren
start to go against each other to any
degree to try to distinguish themselves
from each other often just being lumped
together as the two progressives the
other question was would Bernie and
Warren either together or separately
start to go after Joe Biden now that he
is sort of within striking range and the
answer was Bernie went against Biden way
harder than Warren and I I may just not
be remembering but I don't really
remember Warren going after Biden at all
maybe once sort of lightly but Bernie
went after a Biden on the Iraq war vote
Bernie went after Biden on health care
and some of those moments were arguably
Bernie's best moments now what did not
go so well for Bernie he unfortunately
either had some kind of bronchitis or
was just hoarse from so many events but
he had like a half lost voice he didn't
lose his voice but particularly the
first half of the debate his voice was
not strong and by sheer you could say
it's chance or if you're more
conspiratorial you could say it's
because ABC wanted to help Elizabeth
Warren very often both Bernie and Warren
would rebut what Joe Biden would say but
it would almost always be Elizabeth
Warren who got the first opportunity and
as I've said before even though they
come from different political
backgrounds Bernie and Warren end up
very similar on policy and thus their
rebuttals to Joe Biden were very very
similar and merely by virtue of
Elizabeth Warren getting the first
rebuttal against Biden and Bernie
Sanders getting the second rebuttal
which often contained a 90% the same
substance and Bernie had half lost his
voice I think the optics were much
stronger for Elizabeth Warren in terms
of giving her perspective even though as
I said she didn't really attack Biden it
the way that some thought maybe she
would be doing one thing that became
very clear and again this is this is why
we want more depth and I would want way
more with fewer candidates on stage when
you spend 40 minutes on one topic and
you actually are put in a position where
you have to go seventh and explain what
is your policy one dead giveaway that
you don't really have a policy that's
unique in any way is when the candidate
would be asked like the sixth person
would say okay what is your position on
what should happen with trade and they
just talk about how Trump is doing
things that are bad and restate very
general principles on trade this became
very very transparent with a number of
different candidates there was no you
know Kamala Harris on trade had nothing
unique or relevant to say she criticized
Trump it's like you're running against
each other to go against Trump you all
disagree with Trump I would limit the
amount that you're attacking Trump at
this point in the third debate and had
nothing particularly interesting to talk
about with regard to trade there were a
lot of examples of this a strong moment
for Beto or Rourke was when he was asked
are you gonna just confiscate ak-47s and
ar-15s or what are you gonna do and it
was sort of a right-wing framing of the
gun question but I respect that Oh for
saying yes we are we are going to
confiscate them other countries have
done it what what's going on here is a
disaster we are going to confiscate some
of those really deadly weapons the
pro-gun crowd is going to hate it either
way the pro-gun crowd is going to say
that the entire debate was filled with
people that want to grab guns even if
they don't say it even if you don't
agree with the policy I actually respect
Beto for saying it Andrew yang had his
best debate by far and I got a lot of
emails from yang gang people who felt
that he didn't do so well I think he
actually did did his best where he
suffered is he's almost too polite and
he will stop short of his full speaking
time rather than going over it and this
was one of the reasons why his speaking
time was low also they just don't go to
him nearly as often he made a joke at
the beginning of when talking about
health care about I'm Asian so I know a
lot of doctors or something like that
and I actually do find it funny when he
says stuff like that when he says I'm
the opposite of Trump I'm an Asian guy
who likes math or whatever
I don't know if it actually endears him
to people or if it's just kind of a
thing you hear a candidate say where it
feels like he's there trying to get
attention I'm sort of blind to it
because I'm so sucked into this stuff so
I'd be curious what you think about that
on speaking time Biden and Warren got
the most followed by Booker then Bernie
Kamala Harris mayor Pete Castro
Klobuchar Beto and yang with the least
speaking time not surprisingly overall I
believe Elizabeth I don't know who won
it it was less clear in this case I
think Elizabeth Warren did really well I
think Andrew yang had his best debate so
far who Leon Castro was very strong on a
number of issues including immigration
and criminal justice reform senator
Bernie Sanders was strong said the right
things but again was diminished with the
hoarse voice and by virtue of having to
go second after Warren in a lot of the
rebuttals but those are the four that I
think did the best some people on
Twitter yesterday were saying Kamala
Harris crushed it I don't know I don't
know what to bait you watched I didn't
see Kamala Harris crush anything but in
the end I don't expect big polling moves
other than maybe within the top three
and the reason why is Warren Biden and
Bernie have substantive records on
policy beyond everybody else on stage
they have pre-existing bases of support
they have sort of different visions
generally about how they would govern
and they have constituencies that just
don't really allow that much room for
other candidates so quite frankly
there's not that much support for the
other candidates to gain because the top
three now have solid bases of support we
will see how the polls changed between
now and the fourth debate which will be
again a two-night thing with eleven
candidates October 15th and 16th I think
it is a mistake to be adding more
candidates we should be calling them
even more but alas that is not the case
Warren Castro yang Bernie not in any
particular order the winners of last
night's debate agree with me disagree
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash PAC
blink Asst is a great service that I use
all the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular nonfiction
books including the newest bestsellers
they condense them into 15-minute
audiobooks that you can listen to and
you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you'd like
it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be li NK is t.com /p a que
mas